Andrea Morton it's been a long time it
has indeed I've been counting the days
yeah me too
overriding impression of Megan someone
who's very cave capable smart considered
camera-ready
someone who's determined and ambitious
tell me about your research into her
book I live part of the year in Pasadena
in just outside LA and that's where
Megan had boyfriend's where she went to
school where she appeared on stage so
even before the engagement was announced
people in Pasadena was he was just part
of the normal conversation so I got a
real head start because I knew people
whose kids went to the same school the
boyfriend lived down the same street as
the place where she would well she went
for English breakfast tea so there was a
kind of a sense of this as a local girl
made good what people came to talk to
you were they happy to talk about Megan
three years well some were someone I
mean that certainly school teachers were
drama teachers some of her friends a
couple of you know some members of her
family were yeah what impression did you
get of her when she was at school I mean
she she had quite a challenging
upbringing I mean it was it was
comfortable but it was challenging in
some ways yeah I think I think this good
description it was you didn't want for
food but she did one for certainty and
she always felt being biracial with the
white father and a african-american
mother she always felt she could never
join any particular group either the
african-american pupils or the Asian
girls or and you know she always felt
she didn't quite belong so there's that
sense of not belonging being different
feeling different is is something which
pervades those early years and how did
that manifest itself
for her would you say well it manifested
itself in specific areas where she would
join various clubs so that she didn't
have to sit up her own sit on her own at
lunchtime she she always felt a sense
that she wasn't really part of the gang
as he were she felt different at the
same time she rised that she was a very
smart girl and that people wanted her to
know her because she was smart she was
you know top of the class or thereabout
she became increasingly more popular
though didn't she she got older well she
was it wasn't like she wasn't popular
initially she was she was just confused
about her identity and there's a you
know there's a story she tells of when
she was filling in various boxes in us
in a school form and one of them he said
are you african-american and Caucasian
and so on and there was no box for being
biracial so she didn't know what to do
so she's confused about that and just
her father and he said well draw your
own box and that served for her as a
template going forwards draw her own box
be her own person her parents weren't
together that long
were they they weren't married that long
her parents married for about two years
it was when she was barely walking when
she was a toddler they split up
and that was very a pattern of her her
family background that the fathers were
around and they split up after two or
three years so there's a sense of all
was something changing in there and
during the week when she was younger she
lived with her mother basically
full-time and then during the week
because her father's was working at ABC
Studios which is just around the corner
from her school called Immaculate Heart
she she would stay with him and then see
her mother at weekends there was some
confusion if that's the right word I
don't know it'd be interesting to see
which one you use about what her
mother's role was local people and step
brothers and sisters wanted people to
think that mum was more like the Mae
and they described her in that way
because of the color of her skin
well Doria is is african-americans he's
dark-skinned and Megan is very
light-skinned and many people didn't
even know she was biracial and went and
they lived in an area called Woodland
Hills which is predominantly white quite
Jewish and when she would take Megan out
in the pram people will say oh you the
nanny and it didn't help either that she
didn't have a very good relationship
with Tom
Tom's eldest daughter Yvonne who now
calls herself Samantha and according to
her her brother she used to call him
Dorie of the maid so it didn't he didn't
lend itself to a very happy family
interaction how do you think that shaped
her as a character I think it shaped
it shaped Megan in the sense that she
became quite diplomatic in the way that
many children of divorced parents are
there used to kind of balancing and
juggling the differing demands and
emotional concerns of the pair of the
father and the mother and even the there
comes a time where they starts a mother
their own parents she seems to be very
charismatic we saw the interview with
her for the engagement and dominant but
certainly knows how to work a room was
that your impression very much so I mean
she's been networking working rooms I
mean you know she'd be a journalist she
was she was sitting where you're sitting
now if if she decided to go down a
different path she could have been a
diplomat she could have been a
politician she is she's more of an
activist than the other members of the
royal family have been I'm thinking
specifically of Diana she and from an
early age she learned to speak out to
say her piece and to make her voice
heard how would you compare it to Diana
well they both had parents who divorced
so they felt diana at school felt
different because she was the child of a
do
his parents Megan felt different because
she was biracial they differed in the
sense that diana was very shy she hated
to be in plays she said that she's only
a appear in a play a school play if she
stood at the back and didn't have any
lines to learn megan of course always
wanted to be an actress and they enjoyed
the whole sense of performing and also
academically megan was top of the class
diana as she said herself was a bit of a
twit do you think Diana would like her I
think Donna would warm to her and
respect her as well because the one
thing that performing on stage has done
for Megan is that she's being able to
speak out on podiums as conferences
think on her feet and he's very
articulate diana because he was
essentially shy as a child found speech
making which he wanted to be known for
she wanted to be known as a royal
workhorse as opposed to a clotheshorse
she just felt that her speech making was
a rather stilted as a mum I'm always
thinking are you gonna be good enough
for my son
I'm guessing diana would have been the
same with harry course yeah I mean I
mean and the same with Kate you know is
this the right person and it's pretty
clear that that Harry was besotted with
Megan from a very early stage and that
they were making plans for the future
long long before the engagement was
announced perhaps even the year before
so you think that she would have wait
her up realised that she was going to
make her son very happy and that's all
that well I think she was sooner said to
herself right what's the emotional
connection and then you could see that
they're very touchy feeling the very
much in love and also what does she
bring to the party and she would have
said well she's she's you know she's
already being a humanitarian she's
already being an activist she will bring
something different and something
vibrance and more energy into the royal
family and I think and also you know
she's pursued the agenda of gender
equality
women's rise something that Dyna herself
was very interested in interested in
she'll get on with Kate I think that
Kate and her will be a great double act
for this you know like Fergie and Diana
well up to a point
Lord copper I mean Fergie and Diane I
got on very well until Fergie into the
royal family and then there's a degree
of jealousy
but I mean and and and and and Diana
didn't really conform to the kind of
attitudes that Fergie had towards
monarchy and the royal family that's my
point
I think that's your point I mean I think
that with Kate Middleton you see someone
who is very reserved very considered I
think we see with Megan mark or someone
who is very considered very thoughtful
two young women who know there are mines
and know how to get what they want so
just does that mean they'll get on I
think that I think that I think that
they'll recognise that they have to get
on and I think they'll recognize that
that Kate one day is going to be Queen
Megan when all the who has stopped she's
going to be the wife of the man who's
six in line to the throne but she's used
to being a center stage well she's she's
used to being sent a stage or in actual
fact she's used to being a team player
in a you know in a drama ensues where
she was one character amongst five or
six and I think that you see throughout
her career this willingness to be part
of the team and I think that will be a
great asset and a necessary asset for
her going forward because I think the
one thing she's smart enough to
understand that you don't come into an
institution like the monarchy which has
been around for a thousand years and
throw your weight around you sit still
you wait you listen you take notes she's
an incredibly as we said clever
articulate young lady she has been
auditioning for a long time for the role
of princess isn't she I think she's been
auditioning for a long time for the role
as an actress I mean you know one of the
things that struck me about her life is
that she only just got in on
the wire and this in the series suits
the age of 30 at a time in Hollywood
when people are saying well actually
over the hill she it's interesting again
going back to the interview I rewatched
the engagement interview last night and
she sort of almost seemed to misremember
how much she knew about the royal family
she said she didn't really know Harry
very much but of course in your book you
give the impression that she knows she
knew a lot about the the Royals growing
up in the book I talk about the fact
that she was she knew about Diana she
watched the funerals she and and she was
she and her friends were inspired to you
know collect toys and and give them to
needy children so there was that element
to it it's it's a bit like knowing about
Donald Trump in Britain you know you
know that the headline stories you don't
know all the minutiae of what he's doing
day by day whereas in America you tend
to do that it's the same for far she was
an American who knew something about the
royal family obviously she knew the
headlines he knew the main players but
she didn't know all the other details
and I mean well I mean he was eligible
bachelor in the world she knew who he
was of course it but I mean you look at
that footage before she met Harry where
she was asked William or Harry and she
kind of looked nonplussed I mean you
look carefully at that she was she was
thinking who the hell are Harry and
who's William and and that answer was
she had to be prompted in the answer oh
yes I'll take Harry you've written a lot
about other Royals as well haven't you
apart from just Diana who do you think
she is most comparable to of course many
people will compare her to Wallace
Simpson the fact that she's been married
before the fact that she's American the
fact that she's she carries herself in a
certain way she's glaring glamorous and
star really well you can compare it to
several people queen Letitia okay
Queen Leticia used to be a journalist
initially she used to be a TV presenter
she was outspoken she was articulate she
was divorced she was a member of a part
of the family who were basically
Republicans and she moved into the royal
family and she learned to remain silent
and to adapt to a different lifestyle so
I would choose first of all Letitia as
very similar I also put Dyna obviously
and Wallis Simpson there because what
was Simpson
was glamorous in her own way stylish in
her own way as is Meghan she was also
sharp Sparkie and very smart again like
Megan Margaret
Princess Margaret Margaret was more of a
rebel and more of a more grand than
Megan is I think would she be allowed to
be that potentially more than Kate
because she's not gonna have to you know
fulfill the role that Kate will she know
Kate's gonna be queen Megan's no never
gonna have to have that heaviness of
responsibility no see she can have fun
with it she can have fun with the role
and she can explore it and I think that
and she can be as it were the the the
bird down the mineshaft for the royal
family to test out things because she's
she and Harry are seen as as kind of an
interesting couple
they're a power couple aren't they I
think so I think that they're
individually they're not as strong as
they are together I think it's it's that
it's the Burton Taylor it's it is it is
the fact that they together they can
change the world and it's something
which inspire them both as they were
making the conversation that that he
realized that was somebody by his side
who is articulate and intelligent and
also experienced in some to some degree
in humanitarian work they work together
they can make a big difference
he's transformed over the last few years
hasn't he I mean you talk about him
again in the book and and how he was
when he lost his way a bit and but now
you see him Invictus games articulate
considered young man
who
no wonder he was the most eligible
bachelor in the world well it was the
most eligible bachelor because he's
because because of his position and he's
his birth but he's actually independent
of his birth and the privileges enjoyed
he's shown himself to be a young man
with with fiber and calibre and going
forwards he's shown himself that yes
he's had his probably his major issues
and let's not skirt around those the
grief that he felt after his mother's
death the way there's an angry drunk who
didn't know how to behave himself for a
time first time absolutely as I say in
the book he was an angry junk who come
out of nightclubs looking to pick a
fight with paparazzi and and certainly
if the Queen had been faced with the
option of can I marry make this American
actress mega Markel who's just been
divorced the Queen might have thought
well just think again young man what do
you think of Harry nice I think that
Prince Harry is a young man transformed
and a young man that's a testimony to
how good the military is that changing
people's characters and in a way he's
he's turned into the young man that
we've all wanted him to be and that he's
always going to have that halo of diner
surrounding him and people can see that
he's got that aspect of her character
inside him someone whose wants to give
back more so than William well Williams
always been a different character as
Diana would have said he's more than his
more Germanic he's more solid he's more
serious he's more cautious he's
articulate and his intelligent he was
making a speech the other day and
somebody was remarking just how good he
was on his feet didn't need any notes he
just spoke so he's he's a worthy
successor to to any member of the royal
family how's he gonna cope when he has
to start to protect his wife because
they would you know what we're British
we build people up to knock them down
there will be a moment when the
criticism starts to build against Megan
wonder how she might deal with it I
wonder how he might deal with it well I
always used to say
don't read the newspapers and of course
watch this you do she read the
newspapers so the first thing that
Megan's going to stop doing is reading
the newspapers and you're absolutely
right we build people knock them down
there'll be all kinds of stories all
kinds of pictures up here in in the
continental press if not in the British
press but as she says herself it's all
noise so if I just get on with what I've
got to get on with I'm fine and you know
most members that are all family they
treat what the mass media are doing as
noise they don't listen to it that it
read about it they get a briefing in the
morning on a little bulletin board and
they'll read the main points they won't
be reading about what some Fleet Street
maven is writing about them you know
she's gonna be a princess she's not a
saint she she has had again as she point
out in the book you know when she got
married and then she decided that she
didn't want to be with Trevor ankles
anymore she said she sent the rings back
in the post well she was she's certainly
calculating and she's certainly someone
who when she makes a decision to go
through with it and that's something
that she says herself that she's
thoughtful and she's considered and and
in her defense she was in Toronto and he
was in Los Angeles and you know nobody
really knows why marriage ends but it
did end and very abruptly and he was a
bolt out of the blue as far as he was
concerned as far as many of her friends
were concerned I've Howard will it be
for her to build a life here in the UK
do you think cuz you know she is
American through and through I think
it's going to be difficult for him I
mean it's there'll be some long nights
of the soul where she's thinking you
know they told me that a walkabout was a
very carpet event but there's no red
carpet it's raining it's cold and people
all they want to talk about is the
weather you know so it'll be the the
little details of how does she get a
nice ripe avocado in this in central
London how does she find decent hot yoga
instruction all these things that she's
used to she's led a gilded life
I mean she's being used to catching
planes like other people can't stack
says she's got you know one year she was
in 12 countries either on holiday or on
humanitarian missions she didn't need
anybody's permission to do what she did
she was she had a very successful blog
the tag she had instagrams she and a
couple of million followers she was very
popular in her own ride and then how he
comes into her life and she has to start
again so she can see of course there's
gonna be some difficulties but she can
also see it as a great adventure do you
think the mixed race challenge is going
to be a challenge yeah well Megan's
already have suffered from some racist
remarks but growing up in Los Angeles
and seeing the LA riots and having some
of the abuse that she saw hurled at her
mother she knows about this I mean you
know as someone who's biracial and also
light-skinned
going to school going to going to
college people treated her as if she was
Caucasian and they would make remarks
about black people about
african-american people so she's been
used to that and I'm afraid it comes
with the territory
yeah Harry said that the stars were
aligned and that's why they got together
but she was the fourth woman that he'd
taken to Africa yeah I have to say it
makes me smile because when he said
let's go to Botswana she was thinking
wow how fantastic and I was thinking
that the courtiers at Buckingham Palace
will be going mmm the fourth woman the
seventh trip to Botswana
this guy's got style yeah okay so he cuz
he had to take another girlfriend Sam
and but in a way it was his way of
testing them to see you know is there a
kind of an emotional connection there
and clearly there was because they
certainly fell in love in though in
there's a few days that they spend in
Botswana what is it about Botswana for
him do you think they start just dies
Africa if you've ever been to Africa
ever been on Safari you in you with the
earth you
with life and death is you've got these
grand vistas it's incredibly romantic
and it's interesting that both Prince
Charles and every of the 8th the form of
Prince of Prince of Wales took his
mistresses to Africa
it's a place it's a very big Eiling
continent this is going to be a marriage
that lasts well I think every will be
giving it a fair wind and and hoping so
because they're a genuine couple who can
make a difference to the world and I
think that they're aware of that and
it's not like a trap a quick
relationship they were they spent some
months together before the relationship
became public they knew what they wanted
each other and you can see that in the
fact that during the courtship Megan
would be flying in from Toronto to spend
two days with Prince Harry now that's
what I call love that's what I call you
know dedication and and Harry was doing
the same thing taking plane rides to
Toronto to see her for a couple of
nights so they obviously they were they
were totally loved up and going forwards
they have that humanitarian vision that
to make a difference that will sustain
them when they become more than more
than just lovers and when they become
companions so your prediction is happy
ever after I hope so and I would drink
well I'm not dodging yes yes happy ever
I'm just going to try and put it in
context okay happy a happy ever after I
think that Megan Megan's be married she
knows what she wants she's and and she's
found the man of her dreams
and Harry's absolutely right the stars
are aligned all that you know Dinah died
at 36 Megan is 36 she's been in a funny
kind of way picking up the torch picking
up the baton that lives dropped by Diana
Japan thank you
thanks a lot